[Music]
africa
large diverse and complex is changing
rapidly and profoundly
[Music]
for europe africa is a key geopolitical
partner
together we are building a renewed
strategic relationship with shared
responsibilities and mutual benefits
but it can be challenging for
policymakers to identify development
opportunities that are sustainable
they need up-to-date knowledge to be
able to tackle complex issues identify
trends and shape the future
what if we could support them with a
wealth of data about africa's water
needs food security digitalization
about jobs health and migration flows
and what if it was all in one place
we have designed a website a single
entry point gathering knowledge on
africa's social economic territorial and
environmental development
you need to know where the last
undisturbed tropical moist forests are
in madagascar and whether they're
protected
a collection of geospatial datasets
gives you insights on more than 30
topics from continent to country level
are you looking for information about
electricity access in rural senegal
and where best to invest in renewable
energy
interactive tools allow you to explore
selected topics in a tailored and
detailed way
can we monitor gold mining in the congo
using satellite imagery
a series of stories illustrate how
scientific research can support policies
are you looking for a partner in morocco
you'll find details about the main
african institutions with whom we
collaborate
the platform is easy to use visual and
up-to-date
it is highly interactive and connects
many topics
our ambition
to support the africa eu partnership
share knowledge and help our partners
shape a sustainable future for africa
bye